ho sempre avuto un rapporto molto fisico
con le cose con tutti gli oggetti che mi
circondano fin da bambino ricordo la
magia delle forme dei colori le
sensazioni che mi regalavano al tatto
d'altronde crescendo con un padre
artista e rapporto con la materia è
sempre stato enfatizzato e valorizzato
rapidamente sviluppare una passione per
gli oggetti quasi un'ossessione non per
qualunque oggetto ma solo per quelli
belli non c'era una ragione ben precisa
è una cosa di pancia che veniva da
dentro il mio rapporto con gli oggetti
era estremamente intimo in pochi secondi
li smontavo per vedere come fossero
fatti all'interno ma non sempre riusciva
di ricomporli una volta smontati
sezionati analizzati li mettevo la parte
per me erano archiviati ormai sapevo
tutto non avranno segreti col tempo
questo mi permise di creare una certa di
banca dati una conoscenza personale
degli oggetti è abbastanza estesa e
anche di sviluppare alcune capacità
manuali relative all'uso di atene di
utensili e materiali vari
un'altra cosa che mi ha sempre
affascinato è vedere le persone lavorare
lavorare con le proprie mani
gli artigiani in particolare l'artigiano
perfeziona il suo gesto
grazie alla ripetizione dell'azione
la scelta del giusto utensile la mano
ferma lo stile d'altronde sono capacità
che si allenano un po come la matematica
o il disegno o le lingue ma proprio
perché si tratta di un allenamento è
fondamentale cominciare quanto prima ad
allenare le proprie mani
a sentire la fiducia nelle proprie mani
è una cosa che da bambini facciamo
abbastanza quotidianamente e in maniera
naturale ma crescendo spesso può passare
in secondo piano
e questo può rappresentare delle
difficoltà il poca fiducia in se stessi
nella trasformare le proprie idee in
realtà
le idee soprattutto appena nate sono
fragili effimere hanno bisogno di molta
cura in mano ferma per essere
trasformati in realtà è proprio lì che è
necessario sviluppare la propria
conoscenza di se stessi e la propria
fiducia per procedere a trasformare le
idee in oggetti fisici
spesso la prima materializzazione di un
oggetto la prima realizzazione fisica è
un prototipo e non sempre prototipi si
presentano in questo ordine in ordine
logico in maniera pulita ordinata
si tratta semplicemente di provare
alcune assunzioni verificarle per poi
procedere alla successiva
la maggior parte delle volte si
presentano più come un'accozzaglia di
cose scotch filo di ferro e tanta
pazienza ma proprio in momenti come
questi che si può più sentire liberi di
pensare con le proprie mani
questo che vedete piccolo giallo in
basso a destra è stato il primo
modellino il mio progetto di carrello
valigia per bicicletta risale a sette
anni fa quello che vedete alle spalle è
stato il primo prototipo due anni più
giovane
dico prototipo perché la caratteristica
del prototipo e di essere almeno
parzialmente funzionante dico almeno
parzialmente perché effettivamente
quello sviluppa abbastanza rapidamente
però diciamo che per qualche metro
funziona ricordo quando scatta in questa
foto piuttosto soddisfatto ero nel mezzo
della svezia con i miei amici miei
compagni di viaggio e finalmente un
prototipo funzionante
erano passati da qualche metro a più di
mille chilometri in realtà ricordo anche
bene come al rientro dopo qualche
settimana
mi resi conto di quanto fossi lontano
dal mio obiettivo lontano dall'oggetto
che volevo realizzare e fu lì che in
seguito all'ennesima discussione perche
i miei compagni di viaggio e di progetto
e per sé anche un po fiducia nella mia
idea fu un piccolo fallimento in realtà
ma è proprio in momenti come quello che
è ancora più necessario continuare a
metterci le mani davvero per sentirsi
sempre più liberi di sbagliare
rapidamente imparare dai propri errori e
crescere da questi prima o poi col tempo
e con la passione risultati si ottengono
sempre spesso sono diversi da come ci
eravamo aspettati all'inizio da come ci
eravamo immaginati
ma questa fa parte della magia del
processo creativo
la vera difficoltà certe volte ai capire
quando un progetto è arrivato al
traguardo quando un progetto è finito
dopo un po di anni di esperienza come
designer sinceramente la mia esperienza
che i progetti non si finiscono mai ma
si abbandonano un certo punto è
necessario fare ciò per lasciarli liberi
di andare nel mondo altrimenti il
rischio è di mantenerli solo per sé
continua reiterare nel tentare di
perfezionare un oggetto e alla fine non
presentarlo ma nel mondo
la mia sfida è proprio crescere passando
all'oggetto successivo passando al
progetto successivo ivan scinardo
fondatori di patagonia è l'imprenditore
è che mi ha più stimolato nel fondare la
mia start up e intraprendere questo
lavoro da imprenditore il suo approccio
radicale ma sostenibile al prodotto è il
progetto mi hanno folgorato e mi hanno
fatto capire quanto il prodotto e il
progetto stessi possano giovare dall
approccio imprenditoriale e viceversa
ora mi rendo conto che parlare di start
up e di design possono essere passioni
non condivise da tutti qui ma è proprio
lì che vi sfido a cercare le vostre
passioni ad analizzarle a cercare le
vostre idee trattarle con cura
trasformarle in progetti quindi in
prototipi e quindi in oggetti trasforma
le vostre idee in realtà mettendoci le
mani veramente come fanno queste persone
quotidianamente sporcandosi le mani per
innovare nel mondo della cucina o come
qualcuno fa scalando montagne e facendo
imprese al limite delle loro capacità
fisiche e mentali o come fanno
moltissimi coraggiosi di noi che cercano
di creare un futuro nuovo per la propria
famiglia
quello che veramente conta
e trovare le proprie passioni dedicarci
a giusto tempo e intraprenderle non c'è
momento migliore del qui ed ora per
farlo le vostre passioni possono essere
la migliore scusa in assoluto per creare
dei nuovi progetti da passioni di
persone comuni sono nate le idee che
hanno cambiato il nostro mondo pertanto
come ci ricordano charles e ray eames
prendete seriamente le vostre passioni
grazie
[Applauso]